I did lilies of the field I had no  thought Alaska none but I was taken with  the material I was I was overwhelmed  with the possibility of trying to create  this particular dye and I did create him  with no thought of Oscar it was the  farthest thing from my mind I can tell  you that I knew I just felt that I was  not going to win but of course I was  there to experience the presence and say  to the the winners well when my name was  called I had no idea was gonna happen I  leaped up from my chair  right there in time  I was saying  the the receipt of the Oscar there is no  honor in the motion picture business  that  exemplifies all the things that one  could possibly reach for because it is a  long journey to this moment I am  naturally indebted to countless numbers  of people principally among whom Ralph  Nelson changed pol William Barrett  Martin bomb and across the memory  Academy all of them it was amazing  amazing amazing amazing